[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to special from the
security and counter-terror
so here's a little taste of what we'll
be bringing you in the next ten minute
Chris tests out Virtual Reality training
to handle attacks by terrorists
I witnessed the taking down of a drone
with a former counter-terror commander
and we've got the terrifyingly weird in
our games review we've come to the
largest gathering of security
professionals in the UK
the security and counter terror acts
both here in London is filled with the
latest technologies developed to help
protect the public and property you see
new kinds of threats are emerging all
the time so innovation is king his crest
you know no silicon falala tackling
terrorism isn't always about Hill has
more firepower
today's radical groups are becoming more
and more tech savvy we've all seen how
Islamic state are using drones to help
spread their propaganda it means
fighting extremism is now about who has
the better gadgets one company is
developing tech that uses radio
frequencies to hack drones and take them
out of action it's a system that can
automatically detect and disrupt drones
engage drones and prevent them from
flying into a designated area we turn
the system on and now it's passively
listening to all the frequencies in the
area when it engages the drone you then
see the lights in the drone begin to
blink yellow which means it's engaged
and it slowly lands of the devices
include early warning systems to detect
rogue UAVs before they become a threat
the creators of this piece of kit say
it's a constant battle to keep up with
the latest drone tech we have to look at
every new drone coming on the market we
even cooperate with the biggest drone
manufacturers that we get drones in
advance before they come to the market
so that we can record the pattern they
are also doing a lot of nasty things so
they can change frequencies and channels
very fast so we have to catch up with
more receivers with bigger real-time
bandwidth and with better software of
course using technology to fight
terrorism isn't all about the
battlefield itself take the controller
virtual reality is becoming a big part
of counter-terror training the objective
of this scenario is by looking for
something you're looking for a search of
this station and you're looking to find
any suspicious items this is a real
catch model of a parcel
a metro station yep and it's used to
train police and security forces to
understand how to evacuate passengers
what are the benefits of using this
instead of using kind of real people
real props and kind of real environments
the benefits of the virtual reality is
that you can replicate scenarios like
explosions or marauding shooters in this
environment that you couldn't actually
do in a real environment Chris Creegan
Sky News this is a mobile drone
detection vehicle it can apparently
sense drones and their pilots the
kilometers
I'll stay with us because coming up I'll
be speaking to the Mets former
counter-terror commander about the
threat of coffee drones that's coming
right up after a roundup at this week's
tech news
Mark Zuckerberg says he's going to hire
an extra three thousand staff to tackle
extremist and distressing content on
Facebook earlier in the week UK MP said
they want social media firms to be fined
if they don't take down illegal content
Google's shut down an email scam
impersonating its Google Docs service
the company says that while the spam
campaign accessed and used users contact
information no other data was exposed
scientists in New Castle have developed
a Bionic hand that sees objects so it
can pick them up with the right kind of
grip a camera attached to the hand takes
a picture of an item enabling the shape
and size to be assessed so that a grasp
can be triggered within milliseconds
apparently and some of the UK's biggest
cities have the worst 4G connections
Bournemouth was bottom of the pile in a
report by which that compared 20 cities
Middlesbrough came out on top London
managed just 16th place in the list it
puts the UK's coverage at 54th in the
world behind Estonia and Peru
stick around for our games review in
just a few minutes we've got a game that
will appeal to fans of two popular
franchises but before that what you're
looking at now is a demonstration of how
a net gun could take down a drone I'm
lucky enough to be able to get some
insights from the former head of
counterterrorism command for the Met
Police who's here with me now Richard
that seemed a little bit basic to me how
effective is that kind of technology
well there are a range of counter drone
measures in existence and that's just
one of them obviously I should emphasize
that most drone technology is very
positive we can see a lot more drones in
the future of drones going to help with
flood mitigation with agriculture and a
range of positive uses but we do need to
be aware that there's a risk that
terrorists might use drone capabilities
to cause harm we've seen Isis use
recreational drones also know the Iraqi
army has used them jihadis how much of a
threat do you think they really are in
the UK we haven't seen terrorists use
drones in the UK but we just need to be
aware that you know terrorists learn by
experience is lamech state and other
terrorist groups have been using drone
technology for a number of years now in
various theaters like Syria in Iraq etc
so what can happen is those technologies
then get used in other against you know
other places such as the UK so we've
already aware this is a real risk and we
need to have a counter measures in place
to combat it let's talk about online
radicalization now how much worse has
that become
you left your posters counter-terror
kirmada well social media has been the
turbo charge on the terrorist threat
it's provided terrorists an opportunity
to you know to reach people around the
world
vulnerable individuals radicalized
online and inspire terrorist acts the
major social media Giants have been
under a lot of pressure recently they
need to crack down on it do you think
they can do more I think they should do
a lot more and you know they need to own
the responsibility to deal with this
problem you know it's very similar to
child pornography you know we should not
be permitting and allowing radicalized
material illegal to be on the Internet
and we've got the capability the
algorithms to take most of this stuff
down and the Internet service providers
need to you know frankly wake up into
this problem and I believe that they
need to you know be encouraged
you know if necessary you know forced to
do more you know you're seeing the the
physical caliphate from the Islamic
state is being slowly defeated but the
fear is now going forward the you know
the virtual caliphate if you like will
continue and if they're allowed to
inspire terrorist attacks from social
media and through the internet with
impunity then were going to see more
attacks that can be prevented video
games time now and this week Simon has
been back to the swipe studio with a mix
of the really weird and Wonder
take a look at this what remains of
Edith Finch for the ps4 and PC is a
video game that's not actually anything
like the video games we're used to
playing you play as Edith a girl that's
going back to her family home to
research our ancestry try and find out
more about her family treat now the way
it does this is you go around the house
and you explore each of the rooms and in
each of these rooms you get some weird
crazy atmospheric story which gives you
insight into her family but also shocks
surprises the story continues to twist
and turn if you're more of a Call of
Duty player or just like taking a gun
and playing multiplayer online you're
probably not going to enjoy this but if
you like a video game to shock surprise
and offer you something different this
is next to perfect
Dragon Quest Heroes 2 is a lot like as
you may expect Dragon Quest Heroes 1
just got a bunch of new content and a
bunch of new levels in there now if you
don't know what Dragon Quest Heroes 1 is
it is a game that takes the dynasty
warriors franchise and it takes the
Dragon Quest franchise and it pushes
them together so you get some crazy in
some weird hack and slash title that's
also MIT with a Japanese RPG this is
more dynasty Warriors than it is Dragon
Quest which means the majority of your
time is going to be swinging a big sword
around as you take out quite literally
hundreds and thousands of enemies it's
very easy to pick up is very accessible
and ultimately it's just a lot of fun
Wilson's heart on the oculus rift is
like no other game you've ever played in
your life and to be honest if it was a
usual game where you just look at it
through your TV screen and have a
controller in your hand I'd probably
tell you it wasn't very good but through
the magic of virtual reality it's almost
incredible does you play a guy called
Wilson who's been admitted to hospital
to have a heart transplant but when you
wake up not only has your heart been
replaced by some weird device that gives
you magic powers but the hospital you
are in is now haunted from here all
you're asked to do is try to figure out
what on earth has happened you don't do
that by fighting Ghoulies or shooting a
gun you literally just talk to people
and explore and the reason it works so
well is because you've got the virtual
reality helmet on your head and you're
so immersed in this world you're
actually going to feel like you're there
and it's so good
you're gonna call up your friends and
say man you've got to come round and try
this cuz I've never seen anything like
it in my life it's special its unique if
you've got an oculus rift i highly
recommend you going place
that's it for this week's show but as
always you can watch any of our episodes
on demand in all the usual places why
not follow us on Twitter at Sky News
fight then you can start to date with
everything we get up to throughout the
week I'll be back with more slightly
next time join us then bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]